[Applaus]
[Musik]
derart und deborah sie endlich die lang
ersehnte wirklich sache
[Musik]
mit interesse
das lebensrecht die kumpels ashley
greene und zwar monatelang mit dem zug
verarbeitet zu arbeiten
[Musik]
war
ich hasse wird
[Musik]
und der ritter
die amerikanerin klemmt im nachtzug
und deine
denn hätten wir uns mit ihnen auch für
leute industrie gemacht und kommen
lassen
ich denke
[Musik]
aber als kollektiv motto der insel brach
kommen
[Musik]
salt lake ist diese feststellung
seither ist der 1
[Musik]
es ist so wie unser bmw a game in neue
welten und wächst jetzt einmal virtuell
[Musik]
der tarif o2 o tel o
[Gelächter]
so geht's anstatt auf interesse an nach
kalifornien
für den lassen
[Musik]
menzel
sich mehr gekauft
doch halt
dieses jahr ganz bestimmt nicht
[Musik]
das ist
nach 38 auf der insel führt ebay das
idyllische platz link
[Musik]
zurück in die zivilisation
sprechen
[Musik]
denkt ihr
während die eltern in krakau im rbb
woche ist die lücke die gates am
mittwoch nichts ganzes lied hallo da ist
es also schon unbedingt du dir jetzt
schon jetzt endlich fest und wartet seit
17 gezogen
eigentlich also deutlich niedriger sein
es wird nur sportfest gehörten
[Musik]
oh mein gott ja so glück kein mensch
dass du mit ihm schon nichts ich will
erst zwei stunden natürlich einfach so
ein ergebnis haben wir ja wohl an seinem
nachwuchs es ist nach wie vor ihm und
vor dem voi weiß dass wenn du ins
mikrofon schwirrt ekliger verteidiger
assist und elias aber nicht neu ist
grüner vw geht womöglich mit es muss
jetzt sehen
[Musik]
hat die stimme
gestern aufs handy
nein
wir haben dass wir sie für die das
studienjahr zu teilen können
[Musik]
ja sehr
höchst
[Musik]
bronze
[Applaus]
wir trafen
[Musik]
der brandort durch sie und wächst im
ökodorf in die hand der crazy metapher
und aufs tor 52
[Musik]
nun wird also keine sorgen
hier wird der brief eines elektro
festival melt wollen somit 2020 wird
stattfinden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wow russland wird für mehr
[Musik]
hallo vielfältig und besonders
das wird ja bewusst guerilla sei man
sich bewusst kreis
die reise zu spazieren versucht die lädt
die rote station ist paris
der vorstoß war sturm zurück nach
bargeld
und was dank pkws bis jetzt
es ist so wenig
fährt man ja das ist gar nicht so groß
sitzt
[Musik]
aber da kann ich meine sommersprossen
denn jede sich so bewusst wenn wir auch
sowie solisten funktionierenden aber
dass ich meiner meinung nach utopie dass
sich vorstellen ich glaube ja ich habe
richtig rund für mich heißt das weniger
konsumieren und mut zu machen wo ich
nicht buche ich brauche ganz vieles auch
und sobald ich 100 ausmachen wenn ich
brauche aber wirklich wichtig ist
wirklich essentiell ist dann dann habe
ich auch viel mit sie zu mir selber
bewusst sie nein ich mit ganztag am
handy heilmann ich nicht die ganze zeit
und die konsumieren ich meine ferien zu
gestalten dass die ganzen aktivität ist
besonders mau aussieht hat es manchmal
partei gegenposition ort danke dann hund
erst irgendwie ein grund doch erst zu
begeistern aber bisschen reflektiere
ziel ist es die natürliche ressourcen
[Musik]
das gros des treff in hamburg im dorf
freundin und kollegin spannstoß dazu
sammer für pläne sind die letzte tag vor
von gc denkt solide liquidität und umzu
wege steht
müde aber glücklich die beide nach vier
wochen wieder zusammen
versprochen
[Musik]
osteuropa betrifft deborah unter martin
geht langsam an die zur natur und
freising ist klar
es wird vielleicht sehen wir das
einschätzen zu können
von
da ich von ca
im video
aber immer der fall
[Musik]
mit dem schauen jetzt wirklich und
konzertiert ich noch ein bisschen sonne
mitbringen
hi nicht immer muss ich jetzt im
lebensstandard in der schweiz fast
vergessen er glaube
habt ihr auch noch viel zeit in
griechenland verpackt so schon auf euch
ja aber wir sind die ganze dann in der
ökonomisch gesehen
doch wir sind ein bisschen verzinst
[Musik]
in bahn ist mir schon zu q4 bericht vor
die jungs fahrt ab sofort die der erste
eigene vier wände
diffuse
da hatten wir glück gehabt das war ein
bruch würde jetzt aber jetzt eine liste
gemacht haben es 835 schieber warum wir
da wo man gleich beim ersten antritt
machen aber auch jede tour wird schon
die ganze wirtschaft ganz schwarz mit
jedem sind david lee zigarren afrikas
laufen girls club nach lennep können auf
das klip insassin petra schmettow
verhinderte zwischen
wasser auffüllen
trinkwasser
[Musik]
bruno jonas
einmal
[Musik]
wird mal wieder zeit die sicherste weg
ist ein supertag
von gold und sie dazu
ich werde mich sehr freue
ja
das schmeckt nach
[Musik]
francesca schwarz wies aber selbst ein
bedarf sogar tiermedizin studieren
machen die spanier gut 88 junge menschen
herr sommer lang in die ecke die
freiheit of china erlaubt ist jedes
europa zeigt und ist auch ueli geschäft
faz.net vor dem sonnenbaden tattoo ich
weiß von nichts da wird sich doch noch
zum beispiel in mannheim
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
oder aber dass der schönste blume
zweitens dass in nationalblume vor dem
landgericht spanien italien frankreich
produkt okay das ganze einfach und auch
jetzt so nicht zurück bin
naja also nicht make-ups lebens arbeit
in barcelona mit zdk und cafés bars und
drogensüchtige mann sitzt tief
foto nic falsch im internet ausgestellt
hat ich werde mir natürlich bietet also
etwas anderes bild und jetzt in hamburg
sie sind andere beschrieben afrika
hervor
[Musik]
[Applaus]